began this week.
He speaks, he did not say much,
which is of the of character,
but it was just enough, many in
Brazil, the breathed easy.
It took two days for outgoing
president Jair bolsonaro, we
can say that now, the break is
silence after losing to the
left this Luiz Inacio Lula da
silva.
Bolsonaro gave a speech on the
presidential palace on Tuesday,
where he promised to abide by
the constitution.
Notably, he did not explicitly
concede defeat, but far-right
leader chief of staff says he
has been given the greenlight
to work with the incoming
government, singling Mr.
Bolsonaro's corporation of a
peaceful transfer of power.
Brazil's supreme court says the
outgoing --
there he is again.
He effectively acknowledge the
loss but as CNN's Paula newton
reports, some bolsonaro
supporters are still not
convinced.
As president Jair bolsonaro
prepared to finally break his
silence, police forces across
the country moved to break up
hundreds of buckets.
Snarling traffic, slowing
supply routes and rattling
already --
.
Police were acting on orders to
use force, or it is that never
came from bolsonaro himself.
Instead, in a terse two minutes
late mint, he said he would
respect the constitution but
neither admitted defeat nor
recognized the results of the
election and had this to say to
supporters blocking roads
across the country.
>> [Interpreter]
Peaceful demonstrations will
always be welcomed.
I methods cannot beat those at
the left, like invasion,
destruction of goods and
restrictions on the right to
coming go.
[End of translation]
>> On the barricades, some of
the protesters mounting
insurgent campaigns nationwide
had this to say.
>> [Interpreter]
This was a statement where he
did not say anything conclusive.
It gives us the impression that
there was something wrong with
the elections.
That is a plus for us to
continue our stand and keep
protesting.
[End of translation]
>> Many here say that they are
committed to a patriotic cause,
standing up for the president
that they elected.
>> [Interpreter]
Country and freedom, just that,
we don't accept --
not just us but a large part of
the Brazilian population.
[End of translation]
>> These protests, sporadic,
unpredictable and yet
productive, are taking a
damaging toll on the economy
and more.
The structure was stuck on the
road overnight, and his wife
fell ill and had to be taken to
the hospital.
>> [Interpreter]
Personally, I am against the
people have made their choice.
And they wanted to lock things
down, they should not do it the
business.
People have to work.
[End of translation]
>> Even among officials that
back bolsonaro, there is a
great reluctance to support any
kind of civil disobedience.
It's the reason that they have
ordered these black Gates to
and, even if police have to use
force.
They do not believe that these
kinds of protests will resolve
any of the division of the
country.
>> [Interpreter]
It will not be a demonstration
or write that will make society
not recognize the result of the
pulse to the victors, the
mandate to the losers, the
acknowledgment of the feet.
[End of translation]
>> After a bruising campaign
and a vague signal from
bolsonaro that he will give a
power to president elect lulu
to silva, Brazil seems destined
for more political division,
now playing out on the streets
and jeopardizing an already
tense transfer of power.
Paula newton, CNN, são Paulo,
Brazil.
Brian with there's editor and
chief of Americas quarterly as
well as vice president a policy
for the American society and
council of the Americas.
Welcome back, Brian, good to
see you.
>> Good to be back.
>> In terms of concession,
recognizing the feet, affirming
it was the other guy that won,
this was as close as we gotta
on Tuesday and it was not for
bolsonaro.
Here is.
>> [Interpreter]
President Jair bolsonaro as
authorized me one prompted.
Based on the law, we will begin
the transition process.
[End of translation]
>> That's bolsonaro's chief of
staff and apparently by
agreeing to the transition of
power, legally, that C is tacit
approval of the election
results so why talk around the
outcome, a notch here, and what
they're, why not just
congratulate the winner?
There is a time where if you
weren't gracious at the feet,
it was political death.
>> Yeah, that's an
old-fashioned take to say
unfortunately in my view.
What we saw today was as close
to a white flag as we were ever
likely to see from president
bolsonaro and his allies.
It's true that bolsonaro did
not congratulate Lula, did not
explicitly recognize his defeat
but he did say that he would
evade the constitution and he
authorized his chief of staff
to say that the transition
would soon be underway.
For those of us who have spent
months now if not longer
worrying about the possibility
of an institutional crisis to
something similar sought to the
United States, following the
2020 election, this was a
pretty big sigh of relief, not
a perfect situation, as you
point out, but it could've been
a lot worse.
>> It took two days to come up
with that two minutes before
bolsonaro and there is some
reporting that he was locked in
negotiations to try to ensure
that he and his family are not
prosecuted once he is out of
office.
Bolsonaro does have some legal
concerns, everything on the
table from corruption to the
mishandling of the pandemic.
How much weight you put into
that reporting?
>> That sounds true.
I think the start of what
happened during the 48 hours
where president bolsonaro
remained totally silent, I
think that story remains to be
told, but what I am hearing and
what is being reported in the
Brazilian press was that, India
and, it was his allies that --
at least come out and and some
level, acknowledge the result.
They have reason to do that
because even though bolsonaro
lost, he's conservative
movement came out of the
selection pretty strong with a
lot of political capital.
Governors aligned with
bolsonaro will broaden
bolsonaro's three most populous
states.
I think all of his former
ministers who ran for congress
won in their elections, so, a
lot of his allies were saying
to him, look, we know that
you're upset, yes, we agree
with you that the system was
against us in their view, but
let's live to fight another
day.
>> Bolsonaro also made
reference to the right wing
success a party in recent
elections, here he is.
>> [Interpreter]
The rate really emerged in our
country.
A robust representation in
congress shows the strength of
our values, god, country,
family and freedom.
[End of translation]
>> President elect Lula desalva
is already facing big
challenges.
How much harder will this all
be without a politically
aligned congress?
>> I think it will be really
hard for Lula.
Expectations are somewhat high
just because Lula who is
president from 2003 to 2010, an
era of bonanza for Brazil.
The road is much more difficult
this time around.
The global economy is harder.
Resilient politics are harder,
it's a much more conservative
country than it was before,
where he will be facing having
to negotiate in some case with
parties, at least for now
working with bolsonaro.
I think a lot of the left and
people who are worried about
democracy in Brazil, they
breathe a big sigh of relief
today.
It will not last very long
time.
>> The other unknown in all
this is house bolsonaro
supporters will react.
There have been many hundreds
of roadblocks and highways
across the country in the finds
at the supreme court order to
clear the way.
New York Times is reporting
this, protesters said they were
trying to create another
disruption that the military
would intervene enabling the
president and the armed forces
to overturn the election.
That seemed straight out of the
Donald Trump election playbook,
which would suggest bolsonaro
and his loyal followers are far
from ready to go quietly into
the night just like Donna trump
supporters.
>> I do think at the same time,
that things de-escalated today.
The risk of massive violence,
the risk of some sort of
concerted effort to either
overturn the result or make
life really difficult for Lula
from day one, there will be
some voices who will be out
there seeking chaos and
confusion, but I don't think
that it will be the majority.
I think that things really do
get better as a result of the
events of the last 48 hours.
>> It does seem like the